people always want to be like follow
your dreams follow your dreams follow
your dreams sometimes your dreams my and
my meet you in a chokehold working makes
you happy like working really makes you
happy like seeing the money makes you
happy so try to make a list of course
that you guys want it's gonna make you
want to like get up in the morning need
motivation what you talk to him and
believe nation
Oh
she's cardi beep and here's my take on
her top 10 rules to success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one hustle for your dreams if you're
following your dreams I have to say this
don't hold everything or any opportunity
that comes your way because you want to
because you're so focused on your dream
a lot of people be chasing they drink so
much
they just want to like do it do it do it
they forgot about getting a job before
that about that you got to pay your own
bills you know a lot of people go
homeless because they out chasing and
investing on their dreams and have a
time period you know have a deadline
like you know if things don't go
together more than five six seven years
you know I'm saying go to sleep again
and dream of another thing you know I'm
saying now because I'm being honest
because people always want to be like
follow your dreams follow your dreams
follow your dreams sometimes your dreams
might and might leave you in a chokehold
you know what I'm saying like if I was
my dream was always to be our rap artist
right but I had to get a job so I had to
focus on my job and then I made money to
follow my dream you know they always as
you follow your dreams make sure you're
making money rule number two
prove people wrong what advice you give
young girls when they're going through a
hard time and somebody might be talking
trash to them what do you say for them
the only thing that makes me happy is
like proving them wrong
yeah like proving them wrong like you
will never be nothing and it's like whoa
today I'm in hot 97 huh yeah absolutely
I'm doing yeah yeah like it's like I'm
on TV ha ha like it's like my music ha
ha like it's like every single time that
I do something big it just empowers me
like working makes you happy like work
it really makes you happy like seeing
the money makes you happy like oh look
at this rule number three network
network you don't matter kiss-ass but
you gotta like
be consistent and be like your bro why
do I gotta beg you like five months trip
so listen to a song people in your dog
is I don't know like we just gained Sun
in your face and this is I be beyond
these people face like knock knock who's
there my mixtape listen to it I have
gone to every radio station and in New
York this radio station they say step up
very seriously
and I just go repeatedly repeatedly
y'all wanna interview yeah I want some
fried chicken like you guys want me to
what's your next event you guys want me
to host a I'll host it like what's good
you gotta go to these clubs you got a
network rule number four set goals I
also made a list of goals that I want to
complete for 2018 besides music career
and that [ __ ] has really helped me a lot
like to just keep on going because I
want to complete those goals as fast as
I can so try to make a list of goals
that you guys want it's gonna make you
want to like get up in the morning and
get encouraged to just work and get this
money also if you want to learn from
more successful women entrepreneurs
check out my 250 for girl boss series
it's free the link is in the description
below people always want to be like
follow your dreams follow your dreams
follow your dreams sometimes your dreams
man and my meet you in a chokehold
rule number five grow people are upset
that you might not be going back to Love
& Hip Hop have you decided on that
situation or is it just no I decided I'm
not going back but it's not because like
no issues or no issues like there's no
issues it's just like I just got a move
on up it's just like I need to grow like
some you know how is used to be about
mush money like any money money money
money yeah like even now like I have a
lot of a lot of TV deals right that I
could take and start doing tomorrow but
I'm just putting a hold on it because
I'm really focusing on this music right
like I know whatever I'm gonna do on TV
I'm gonna have it down pack because I'm
very creative I think about things over
and over and over again I sleep on it so
whatever I will
do is gonna be real good and I feel like
I got that down pack but my music I
wanted I wanted to be respected because
I feel like I should be respected cuz I
I know I'm not putting out garbage yeah
I know I'm not putting out garbage and I
take my time and I spend my money on E
and so it's like I yeah yeah yeah I'm
car D but yeah I don't respect my not
music - you're gonna respect my gangsta
rule number six play your cards right I
want to be a singer one day what do I
need to do to get there one day
well perfect your craft protect your
boys protect your throw I used to think
before you know I'm saying my boys got
messed up so protect that if you gotta
do free karaoke go and do it you never
know who's hearing you you never know
who's listening you never know whose and
who's looking for tally and I gotta be
real with you I'm not gonna be the one
to tell you chase your dream chase your
dream always have a second plan to fall
back on rule number seven listen to your
instincts one of the most special awards
that you went tonight was for Hot 100
song of the year yes with you know with
maroon 5 yep as soon as I heard the song
Amy I don't care what people say about
me I'll get people to like me and I I
have an ear for good music like I know
it's gonna be high I know it's gonna be
kind of mediocre and I was like yo this
song is gonna be so crazy like and
they're for me to see so go number one I
was like yes bingo rule number eight
learn how to deal with haters I really
don't I don't have picking people to be
close to me it sounds like these new
fans these new pages these new blogs
these new people is just like do you
read all that though yeah or are you
pretty good to brush it off I'm getting
more used to it I'm kidding I'm kind of
getting more used to it at first when I
was really nice tarted like getting
popular when I first like got my first
100,000 followers then when I got on TV
it really hurt me like I was depressed
okay words do hurt yeah yeah where's
your hair because it was like me I'm
ugly I never heard that in my life
like it made me feel like like the way I
talk is like it just made me feel like
if like like if a lot of people try to
make me feel like I'm not educated or if
I don't have no manners and I had to sit
down and tell myself like wait a minute
you used to be a dancer yeah I used to
be the top dancer if he wasn't if you
wasn't attractive nobody will give you a
dollar so I embedded that in my head and
then it's like ain't no way nobody could
ever make me feel like I'm uneducated
because okay I'm ghetto but I did finish
school and I went to college yeah and my
and I'm Caribbean so my parents seats
free man is I can't with a fork in a in
a knife y'all rule number nine be
tasteful whatever you do just don't
nobody you see I'm not a blogger I don't
like a lot of these a lot of these
people here they have blogs and the
reason why they here is because they
don't offend your body you know I've
seen this gossip sites that I see on on
Instagram they did it they deliver some
D but see they deliver my destroyer
artist always sweet me it's me sorry
things aren't me that's why you got a
delivery
he's believed and rule number ten the
last one before our very special bonus
clip is have fun
what's poppin y'all is your girl cardi B
and I'm playing what's in my mouth
first up binder clips very not edible it
feels like out like you know I got like
a paper clip
next up bay leaves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's definitely some type of leaf or
something like like a potpourri of
sanity and my breath right now it's most
amazing like next up duck sauce
hmm this is definitely some type of
dressing I'll be hell upset if I get a
salad with that dressing dot oh you see
you know what I'm saying
now this game is out of proportion cuz
everybody know that I love chicken next
up a warhead oh this is Sawa a subtype
of sour candy it is like like a foodie
like a foodie lubricant know what I'm
keep this one in my mouth
and finally cat treats
[Music]
we're getting our food it's definitely
dark pool cause it got like a beefy
flavor but it's not like a beefy flavor
the humans like so I definitely got be
some type of dog or cat food some type
of animal sorry but it's definitely they
give me that type of vibe
now we got a special bonus cup from
cardi B on how to work super hard that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one what are your
instincts telling you to do number two
how will you learn to deal with the
haters and number three what are some of
your big goals everybody be like oh did
she happen overnight no it did it my
[ __ ] no it didn't I did not just submit
it one song and it just pushed I don't
know where overnight I submitted a whole
lot of songs I'm just tired of people
trying to like this credit every hard
work that I've been through and every
tear my [ __ ] every tear and every hard
work every sleepless night people always
feel like I always been like on top of
the world and no because I never feel
satisfied with like what I have I
finally I finally I finally everything
that I work so hard for I finally got it
all I really ever wanted was respect
from other artists and from people about
the grind that I have put on and I
finally getting it and people trying to
take that away from me I'm not gonna let
you take that away from me my [ __ ]
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on Nicki Minaj the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I hate lazy people I hate
laziness I just don't like
procrastination I don't like people that
make up excuse